has boris johnson misled pogba did you
lie to parliament prime minister there
was no party no
kovid rules were broken what does that
actually mean and what could happen if
it is found that he has there are big
questions but the answers aren't so
straightforward the main way to mislead
parliament is to lie when making a
statement in the chamber
opposition mps said boris johnson did
just that by previously denying any rule
breaking took place at downing street
and in whitehall during lockdown
lying to parliament is considered to go
against all expectations for how
politicians should behave it's so
serious even just accusing someone of
being a liar can get you kicked out of
the chamber by the speaker of the house
has lied to this house time and time
again i order the member to withdraw
immediately from the house for the
remainder of the day's sitting he must
lead the house he must now resign you're
gonna have to withdraw misled
not my fault if the prime minister can't
be trusted but while the speaker can
enforce how people speak to each other
in the commons they have no power to
decide whether or not something that's
been said is a truth or a lie
for that there are two codes of conduct
that politicians can be judged by first
there's the ministerial code this is for
mps who hold positions in government it
states that it is of paramount
importance that ministers give accurate
and truthful information to parliament
secondly there is the code of conduct
for mps more generally that contains the
nolan principles of public life one of
these is honesty it says holders of
public office should be truthful
if ministers give inaccurate information
to parliament they're expected to
correct any inadvertent error at the
earliest possible opportunity typically
they'll submit a written statement
clarifying things back in february the
prime minister had to do that after
telling mps that the russian oligarch
roman abramovich had been the target of
sanctions before he actually had of the
duma abramovic is already
facing sanctions and in the sometimes
mps will do the same by raising points
of order and correcting the record
if ministers are accused of misleading
parliament and refuse to retract the
statement they could be subject to a
ministerial code investigation if the
independent advisor or ministerial
interest investigates the allegations
and finds a breach of the code the
consequences are clear
the rules that set out the procedures of
parliament known as ersk in may say
ministers who knowingly mislead
parliament will be expected to offer
their resignation to the prime minister
in 2018 amber rudd resigned as home
secretary over the windrush scandal even
though she said she'd only misled
parliament inadvertently we don't have
targets for removals
but here's the thing an investigation
can only be launched at the instigation
of one person the prime minister that
makes it pretty awkward when he's the
one denying the allegation in the first
place
and even if an investigation was
launched the prime minister is the
ultimate arbiter when it comes to the
punishment in 2020 priti patel was found
to have breached the ministerial code
allegations that pretty patel bullied
home office staff will find that she
broke the ministerial code she
apologized but the prime minister didn't
ask her to resign so what other options
are there
mps can debate what's known as a
substantive motion and then vote on
whether the house of commons accepts the
allegation erskine may says mps could be
found in contempt of parliament but
according to the institute for
government it's not clear what actual
repercussions could come from that in
the end proving that someone knowingly
misled parliament isn't at all
straightforward
if a government has a big majority then
they should be able to vote down any
substantive motions brought by the
opposition party that suggests it
and if a prime minister doesn't want to
launch a ministerial code investigation
then nobody can force them to